collateral beauty is directed by david
frankel and stars Will Smith Kate
Winslet Helen Mirren Michael Pina Edward
Norton and Naomi Harris and Keira
Knightley and a bunch of famous Academy
Award nominated people and a better
title for this movie would have been
collateral damage because that's what
it's going to do to most of these actors
careers but unfortunately that's already
a movie starring Arnold Schwarzenegger
so you won't call out all damage ha ha
fuck you I'll give you a fucking
collateral and it's the story of a very
successful businessman who after losing
his daughter in death retreats into
seclusion he becomes a hermit he refuses
to speak to anyone he has a hard time
emoting his friends are extremely
worried about him and they try to find a
way to help him this film presented
something extremely unique to me and
something that I've never really
experienced when doing these movie
reviews the trailers for this movie tell
you a plot they tell you that this man
is visited by death love and time the
very embodiments of these things and
that they speak to him and try to help
him through this terrible situation
that's what the trailer says yeah that's
really not what this movie is about not
even close I mean the trailers are big
lie this is a giant marketing scam this
film is completely different from that
in one specific way and if I were to
describe the actual plot of this movie
to you right now you would think that I
was revealing a big third-act twist but
I'm actually not the main plot of this
movie is revealed within the first 20
minutes and it's completely different
and the trailers are making you believe
it's a terrible cinematic baton switch
and a lot of other critics and their
reviews are choosing to tell you what
the actual plot of this film is so if
you really want to know what the real
plot of this movie is which isn't really
a spoiler because it's in the first 20
minutes of the movie I'm about to
explain what the actual plot of the film
is the plot that the studio's don't want
you to know the plot that they saw in
the final finished product and went oh
my god we have made a colossal
miscalculation let's just market this as
a spear
Rachele film so if you don't want to
know what the actual plot of this movie
is I'm about to explain it it's not a
twist it's the first 20 minutes of the
movie this is what happens Will Smith is
so broken up over the loss of his
daughter that he is failing at his job
his friends Edward Norton Kate Winslet
and Michael Pena all work for him and
they're worried they're going to lose
their jobs because he isn't getting a
new clients and he's being terrible with
his old clients so when they find out
that he is writing letters to death love
and time because they hire a private
investigator to follow him and she
breaks into the US Postal Service box
Wow and finds the letters and shows them
these letters they hire three actors and
these three actors are told to pretend
to be death love and time so that they
can then approach Will Smith on the
street and say hey I got your letter you
want to talk so that the private
investigator can film Will Smith talking
to this actor and then they're going to
take that footage and his friends quote
friends are going to digitally remove
these actors from this footage to then
show the board at their job Will Smith
talking to no one on the street to prove
that he's crazy and that he shouldn't be
in a position of power there anymore so
they can retain their jobs yeah that's
the actual plot of the film oh my god
no I'm serious that's not a spoiler it's
in the first 20 minutes of the movie the
trailers just lied to all of us it's
incredibly shamelessly manipulative just
like the entire film okay let's forget
about the dumb plot thing and the fact
that that just makes no sense how could
these people have Hollywood technology
capabilities of erasing an entire person
from an iPhone video because that's what
they do
beyond the plot and how crazily stupid
that is this is an extremely flawed
movie with some very good performances
but the real spoilers that I'm not going
get into about what happened towards the
end of this film creates such a logical
flaw an incredible coincidence that
makes absolutely zero sense that ruins
the entire film I could go on forever
about how terrible and manipulative his
friends are I mean this is a guy going
through severe loss and pain and they
hire actors to portray people like death
love and time to go help him deal with
this sorrow so they can film it and make
him look like he's nuts how did this
movie come into existence that's crazy
Will Smith is really trying in this
movie he's an actor I admire a lot but
this is the December Will Smith Oscar
bait movie last year we had concussion
we've had other films like 7 pounds and
Legend of Bagger Vance Ali he does this
from time to time where he just kind of
appears in these really Oscar Beatty
movies Pursuit of Happyness and always
around December ish the incredibly
horribly manipulative characters in this
movie and the awful plot line in the
fact that we never even see his life
with his daughter makes it hard to
connect with his character because we
never see the happy side of his life we
have one scene in the opening where he's
like yeah yeah ah hmm and he's like you
know giving a speech and doing his will
smith is amande and that's it and then
it's like three years later and he's
like I'm sad we never actually see him
with his daughter and one of the biggest
reasons is because the film has a lot of
Secrets and so it's trying to hide
certain things because if we see certain
things then we're going to know certain
things and the film is so concerned with
hiding its twists and turns that it
forgets to just make a heartfelt story
it's one of those scripts that's
constantly trying to make you not notice
certain things so it has to take all of
these weird routes and cut corners to
make the various things that happen at
the end work and it's awful I think this
is a terrible movie it's one of Will
Smith's worst the acting in it is pretty
good and I admire that it's a nice
looking movie it's mostly well shot but
it has an incredibly
hufflepuff that is so mindlessly stupid
that I just cannot believe this many
a-list actors signed onto this film I
can't believe it happened I'm going to
give collateral beauty
adhi guys there's a reason the studio
has buried this movie within the same
weekend as a Star Wars film despite that
incredible a-list talent they're ashamed
and they should be also I want to make
sure you guys know that my promotion
with audible is still going on if you go
to audible.com slash Chris you can get a
free 30-day trial of this amazing
audiobook service you can download so
many hundreds of thousands of audiobooks
to so many different forms like your mp3
player your computer your tablets all
different types of things they have the
legacy Star Wars novels on there and
with rogue one coming out that is a big
thing for me I have checked out a lot of
those there's such a great selection on
audible.com slash Chris if you go there
like I said you get a free 30 day trial
they've been working with me for a while
and I want to thank them and you guys
for using that service thank you very
much for doing that if you go to
audible.com slash Chris as I said that's
a free 30-day trial check it out it is
worth your time they have so much on
that side it is very helpful you guys
are the best thank you so much as always
for watching stay tuned this weekend
because I'm going to be doing a spoiler
field review of rogue one that's gonna
be a lot of fun thanks very much guys
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck when eyes
you
[Applause]
[Music]